cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous gérard
araud bonjour bienvenue de bon matin sur
ce plateau ancien diplomate vous avez
représenté la france à l'onu notamment à
washington à tel aviv ou signés histoire
diplomatique leçon d'hier pour le monde
d'aujourd'hui qui vient de sortir chez
grasset le monde d'aujourd'hui gérard
araud marqué bien sûr par la guerre en
ukraine et cette contre-offensive de
l'armée ukrainienne à la fois dans le
sud mais surtout dans l'est du pays
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres carrés
repris en quelques semaines dit le
président et l'ins qui est ce que vous y
voyez un moment de bascule oui et non
non parce que nous savions déjà que
l'armée russe ne l'emporté pas la guerre
que sur le champ de bataille poutine
n'était pas en train d'atteindre ces
objectifs est bien là maintenant c'est
un tournant au sens où c'est évident où
plus personne à moscou ne peut se faire
des illusions la russie ne va pas gagner
la guerre à court terme
et non pourquoi
et bien donc à l'évidence l'armée russe
ne fait pas ne peut pas tenir face à une
armée ukrainienne qui monte en puissance
sans doute parce qu'elle manque
d'effectif l'armée russe n'a pas
mobilisé alors que l'ukraine qui est
quand même un pays de plus de 40
millions d'habitants a mobilisé
l'ukraine et qu'évidemment galvanisés
par ce que les ukrainiens défendre leur
territoire national on peut se demander
d'ailleurs ce que les soldats russes
pensent faire le le dévouement des
soldats et sans doute d'un niveau très
différent des deux côtés du front et
puis maintenant la question qui se pose
à tout le monde sait que va faire
poutine alors précisément est ce qu'il
faut craindre d'ailleurs est il au
courant véritablement de ce qu'il se
passe sur le terrain on peut se poser la
question est est ce qu'il faut craindre
une réponse là il ya eu ces frappes
cette dernière heure mais ce qu'il faut
craindre une réponse d'envergure une
forme de réaction de fierté donc
maintenant poutine ne peut pas on ne
peut pas dissimuler à poutine la
situation même sur la télévision russe
on avoue que la russie a subi une sévère
défaite donc on dit qu'il s'est retiré à
sotchi
il doit essayer d'analyser la situation
les réponses qu'il pût qu'il peut lui
apporter mais lorsqu'on regarde ses
options elles sont assez limitées s'il
ne veut pas mobiliser la nation russe
que peut-il faire l'escaladent alors
l'escaladent en termes de bombardements
ils ont déjà commencé à bombarder les
infrastructures civiles ce qui je le
remarque est un crime de guerre certains
à moscou appelle de faire encore plus
mais ce n'est pas en bombardant les
infrastructures civiles congrès a cédé
les ukrainiens ou qu'on va gagner la
guerre donc les questions la question se
pose et il n'y a pour le moment pas de
réponse je ne crois pas en l'utilisation
du nucléaire je ne vois pas ce que
pourrait bombarder les russes de
surcroît les rues jusqu'ici ont toujours
été très orthodoxe dans leur conception
la dissuasion nucléaire c'est pour la
défense des intérêts vitaux si les
ukrainiens attaqué la crimée la jeu
j'aurai une réponse peut-être un peu
différente mais pour le moment on ne
voit pas sur le champ de bataille ce que
pourrait faire une arme nucléaire
la guerre ne peut pas être gagnée par la
russie sur le moyen terme ça ne dit rien
du long terme vous qui pratiquez
beaucoup les réseaux sociaux gérard
araud vous avez écrit il ya quelques
jours je vous cite le comportement de
l'armée russe devrait nous rassurer elle
n'est pas belle elle n'est pas une
menace globale pour l'europe nul besoin
de recourir aux armes le couvrir au sort
nous vous en parlons de courir aux arts
ce qui n'est effectivement pas la même
signification
pourquoi avez vous écrit ça non mais
parce que il y à travers l'europe est
sous le coup d'une émotion que je
comprends il y a un jeu un appel général
à augmenter nos budgets de la défense
sur le thème l'europe la russie menace
l'europe la russie n'est même pas
capable de vaincre l'ukraine et donc la
russie ne va pas attaquer l'otan donc je
j'aurais tendance à dire oui le conflit
a
révélé certains insuffisant de nos
forces armées surtout en termes de
stocks de munitions mais non je ne pense
pas qu'il faille que nous augmentions
substantiellement nos budgets de nos
budgets de la défense je dirais que le
complexe militaro industriel
étalez d'après moi et aller peut-être un
peu vite doit-on continuer à parler à
vladimir poutine et le sous jacent de la
question nous ramène à votre livre
emmanuel macron et il a un bon diplomate
pour le faire ben évidemment qu'il faut
parler à emmanuelle pouyé à puccini
parce que la diplomatie c'est pas pour
10 go si avec les belges ou les
luxembourgeois c'est pour négocié avec
le diable nous sommes onze ans une jeune
où il n'y a pas de juge il n'y a pas de
gendarme vous ne pouvez donc pas appelé
le juge pour s'occuper de poutine même
si poutine fait des choses affreuses et
donc à la fin du compte la guerre si
elle se termine la guerre se terminera
par une négociation avec poutine si
poutine est encore le chef de l'état à
moscou alors vous parlez de la voie
réaliste effectivement pour un éventuel
cessez le feu qui viendra peut-être un
jour entre kiev et moscou
vous pouvez peut-être re préciser les
contours de cette voie réaliste dont
vous parlez elle vous vaut des critiques
vous vous dites que c'est la realpolitik
bon mais le problème c'est d'abord il ya
quelque chose que je ne veux que je dois
avouer que personnellement je me fasse
supporter ces les héros dans le canapé
c'est à dire aujourd'hui tout le monde
est prêt à mourir jusqu'au dernier
craignant il faut quand même se ré
comprendre que la guerre c'est quelque
chose d'atroce atroce pour les pour les
ukrainiens c'est eux qui meurt c'est
leur pays qui est totalement dévasté les
oraux de canapés étant ceux qui ne se
battent pas tous les experts tous les
experts aujourd'hui qui disent par
exemple il faut récupérer laluque la
crimée il faut il faut que poutine soit
envoyé dans un tribunal international il
faut que la russie paye des réparations
soyons réalistes c'est impossible ou
alors c'est une guerre mondiale ou alors
comme gekko quand le premier ministre
polonais a dit à emmanuel macron on ne
négocie pas avec hitler j'ai répondu aux
polonais eh bien allez donc dans les
ruines du kremlin obtenir que poutine se
suicider comme hitler a fait à berlin en
1945 tout ça et il y a autour de la
guerre c'est je le crains inévitable une
sorte de rhétorique enflammée ou l'on
perd le contact avec la réalité
donc il faudra et il le faut le plus
vite possible parvenir à une négociation
entre ukrainiens et russes quels en sont
les termes personnellement je crains
qu'aujourd'hui nous ferions plus loin
que jamais de se de cette négociation
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que les
ukrainiens son vainqueur et quand vous
êtes vainqueur vous n'allez pas faire
des concessions et donc en réalité le
discours des innus qui s'est durci au
début de la guerre et 10 et on pourrait
faire un référendum en crimée
aujourd'hui dit je veux récupérer la
crimée et du côté de poutine et
finalement on ne négocie pas quand on
vient de subir une défaite et dont vous
avez le porte parole de poutine qui dit
la russie a toujours les mêmes objectifs
donc je crains que nous ayons devant
nous plusieurs mois de combats vladimir
poutine perd du terrain en ukraine il
n'a pas encore perdu la guerre il s'est
engagé sur un autre front la guerre du
gaz sur cette guerre l'appétit elle
l'emporté peut-il faire plier les
européens je vous avez tout à fait
raison comme il ne visiblement il ne
peut pas l'emporter sur le champ de
bataille il essaye de l'emporter sur le
champ politique et donc ils visent les
européens qu'ils jugent faible qu'il
juge divisé donc ils coupent le robinet
de gaz les européens s'y sont préparés
madame van der leyen est en train de
parler de la stratégie européenne en
face du parlement européen j'ai eu une
note disant que les européens peuvent
faire face à la privation de gaz cet
hiver si l'hiver est modérée grâce à
leurs stocks et grâce aussi au gaz
liquéfié à l'apport de gaz liquéfié nous
verrons mais c'est ce sera un caisse
centrale c'est un moment de vérité elle
ce sera mon du rite et pour l'europe
d'abord parce que nous allons avoir en
italie des élections qui risque d'amener
au pouvoir une extrême droite plutôt
pro-russe ce week-end prochain le
week-end prochain le 25 ensuite parce
que en allemagne fermer le gaz s'est pas
seulement le chauffage des allemands
c'est aussi l'industrie allemande qui
risque d'être de s'arrêter donc ce sera
le moment de vérité pour les européens
l'hiver sera un moment critique pour le
pour l'union européenne le pari que fait
vladimir poutine c'est de tester la
précisément la capacité de résistance
des opinions publiques ces cinq
exactement et que seront les opinions
publiques lorsqu on leur dira d'ailleurs
déjà vous savez même si le gaz ne ferme
pas si le gaz s'ils ont réussi à fournir
tout lagaf' nécessaire vous avez
l'inflation qui s'accélère vous avez la
récession l'économie européenne qui a
qui arrivent et donc
un certain nombre de voix et en france
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite
vont dire c'est à cause de l'ukraine
l'ukraine ce n'est pas la guerre des
français donc en france mais ce sera la
même chose en italie en espagne en
allemagne et donc quelle sera l'attitude
des gouvernements démocratiques face à
la colère d'une partie de l'opinion
publique les ukrainiens paie le prix du
sang vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure
les européens celui du gars ce n'est pas
la même chose c'est peut-être ce que
dira en substance tout à l'heure vous
l'avez dit ursula von der leyen qui a
qui va prononcer son discours sur l'état
de l'union discours qui commence dans
une quarantaine de minutes et qu'on
pourra suivre en direct sur france 24
elle a invité la femme du président et
lens qui a strasbourg lourd et bien sûr
le le symbole en quoi cette guerre en
ukraine et le la démonstration de ce
changement d'ère de ce monde d'hier dont
vous parlez dans votre livre c'est vous
savez c'est le c'est quand même le
retour de la guerre entre des états sur
le territoire européen depuis 1945 il ya
eu la guerre civile en u en yougoslavie
mais c'était une guerre civile
les européens croyaient être sorti
d'histoire il croyait qu'ils avaient
aidé ici un modèle modèle pacifique de
négociation de compromis entre les états
il ne pouvait même plus imaginer que la
guerre se reviennent sur le corps le
continent européen c'est le cas mais de
surcroît c'est l'image du monde du monde
nous sommes vous savez nous avons eu la
guerre froide avec deux grands états qui
dominait le monde et le gérer ensuite
nous avons eu le moment occidental le
trion des états unis après
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique
eh bien c'est fini le gendarme américain
est fatigué rentrer chez lui et de
surcroît vous avez de plus en plus de
grands carnivores qui d'une certaine
manière 10 nous voulons défendre nos
intérêts nous n'avons rien à faire du
reste vous avez la chine mais vous avez
aussi l'inde la russie etc nous sommes
donc dans un monde de comme je le dis le
grand carnivore un monde de puissances
et ne compte que les rapports de force
et donc il ne faut pas que les européens
soient des herbivores il ne faut pas que
les européens sur des bisounours mais
qu'ils se rendent compte des dangers du
monde qui vient cette guerre n'est
peut-être que la première d'une série de
guerre et nous devons agir
donc pour non pas pour faire la guerre
mais pour essayer d'empêcher les
prochaines amant de carnivores dans
laquelle l équilibre également ceux se
rejoue son neveu négocié entre la russie
et la chine la guerre en ukraine a aussi
provoqué ça naturellement et le sait
qu'une chercheurs c'est une erreur
géopolitique majeur ce café poutine
parce qu'il perd sur tous les tableaux
il voit la suède et la finlande
roewe de rentrer dans l'otan ce qu'elle
n'avait pas fait pendant la guerre
froide il voit la pologne augmenter son
budget à 5% du budget militaire à 5% du
pib et naturellement il est affaibli et
il doit se tourner vers la chine comme
potentiellement une protectrice donc
pour lui c'est vraiment une d une
défaite une erreur une erreur absolument
capital les mois à venir seront donc
décisifs merci beaucoup d'être venu ce
matin sur ce plateau gérard araud
histoire diplomatique leçon d'hier pour
le monde d'aujourd'hui c'est un un livre
qui fait des allers-retours le passé
pour mieux éclairer le présent c'est
passionnant chez grasset ça vient de
sortir merci infiniment très bonne
journée à vous merci à bientôt sur ce
plateau on se retrouve juste après la
pause avec damien coq et donc on le
rappelle le dis si une grosse demi-heure
depuis strasbourg le discours en direct
d'une des femmes les plus puissantes du
monde ursula von der leyen elle va
parler à 4 440 millions de personnes qui
me discours sur l'état de l'union à tout
de suite